let's talk about climate change it does
exist contrary to what they tell you on
fox news yeah it exists I thought this
was really really fascinating so in a
discovery that was published in the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Science which I get
obviously scientists have revived a
thirty thousand year old Siberian virus
let's find out a little bit more about
the discovery so despite being frozen
for over thirty thousand years after
thawing pith of iris SCI bacterium close
enough infected a throng of single-cell
organisms given that climate change is
causing the ground to thaw in regions
like the Arctic and part of Alaska
scientists fear that the lab experiment
could eventually lead to spontaneous
revival of ancient and unknown diseases
so basically stuff that has been
underground and frozen for a long long
time thousands and thousands of years if
not longer I know they say that what was
it Jesus rode to Texas on a dinosaur and
six thousand years ago thanks but even
before that that because the ground is
thawing that suddenly we may release all
these viruses and bacteria and toxins
and all kinds of stuff that should have
been gone a long time ago this is sort
of an angle on climate change that
nobody talks about and that's why I
thought it was really cool because two
of my favorite movies outbreak and
contagion so I do believe in these kinds
of things I also watch Walking Dead so I
assume a zombie outbreak is gonna happen
it's something like this a little
scarier maybe then the sea level rising
which will happen so slowly that we
won't even know until we're swimming but
like a disease could just does that seem
scarier to you could could this maybe
make it a little more it seems very
scary and I never heard that before what
did you what did you like I found that
in the Proceedings of the National but
um yeah this is very frightening I never
even thought about that yeah and maybe
some frozen like person was gonna go
we'll get Phil Hartman back
right we're gonna you know thought
Megatron I had to get some sort of
transformers reference in here um yeah I
mean does this is this something that
maybe will push some of the skeptics to
say uh-oh unfortunately you so far New
York has become a place where hurricanes
just happened now that's like we've all
just accepted that after hundreds of
years of no hurricanes now it's just
like oh yeah and where every year so
there's gonna be a huge hurricane in New
York City like within a year now that's
just an accepted thing snowstorms this
year are also part of global warming
like inclement weather surprisingly
attainable warming I'm sorry because
they go now climate change that comes
inclement weather comes from that this
is just I mean this is amazing like if
this doesn't scare people so I totally
agree with that I don't think there's
anything that you could present them
with because the scientific community we
talk about this all the time
is in unison that this is happening but
the people that don't believe it simply
don't believe it and that's why we have
this crazy false equivalency every time
it's debated on cable news they put on
someone who doesn't believe in someone
who does believe but that's like saying
let's debate gravity it's happening it's
here I haven't watched it the Bill Nighy
Kenneth we're gonna talk about that a
little bit later but right so they're
debating things that are one is based in
fact and one is based in big horror or
fictional fictional book so so what do
we think that although this could be
based in what a great day for dead
eighties authors I mean Tom Clancy has
to be smiling about an evil Russia and
Michael Crichton is up there looking
down being like I never wrote this one
this would be great that's funny
Russia's back with evil the diseases are
back but but really what can we so what
can we do as rational people what can we
do to have a debate about this that's
gonna make sense because if this doesn't
prove it if the sea levels rising don't
prove it if the crazy weather things
don't improve it fear of disease
whatever it is is there just nothing is
it just what is it in these people
that's what I'm always curious about
when I see the people arguing against
its
to go back it's education its
indoctrination and it starts when
they're really little and you know when
you're dealing with people who don't
want to know the truth and they teach
their children that and their children
grow up believing that you know you've
there are monsters creating monsters
yeah it's I think part of the problem is
that religion has always been threatened
by science when it shouldn't be
religious belief can go with science you
can be a Christian a Catholic and
believe that God created science that's
an acceptable you know create if you
want to believe in creationism okay like
believe God does not like you believe in
intelligent design but you don't believe
he could have designed us to evolve from
apes like where where's the line in your
fiction you know and I think we used to
be a leap of faith and now it seems like
it's like a leap over a giant cavern
like you used to be this tiny thing you
would have to take a leap of faith to
say I'm a believer and now it's like I
have to ignore a tremendous amount of
stuff I'm not and it doesn't make any
sense
because when you look at you know I'm
really excited that you know Neil
deGrasse Tyson is relaunching cosmos
been talking about it just amazing but
one of the great things about the
original cosmos and about what Neil
deGrasse Tyson does in Bill Nye and all
these guys that they really are
awestruck and you know the wonder of
science like it is amazing and it is
beautiful and it is surprising and
awesome and you would think that that
actually dovetails really nicely with
really this place but kids are raised
and people are so threatened by the idea
that oh if we acknowledge that these
things are true then where does that
like where is our red line where do we
stop where you know do we have to admit
that Jesus you know wasn't born on
December 25th they feel that it shatters
their reality so you know so so they
basically denying it because it's safer
it's easier they're scared it's well
it's like the advertising is all about
fear yeah it's all about fear look at
the three of us left-wing intellectual
types crapping on the right-wingers